Wow.
There was a lot to learn in this lesson.
Now that we've got an understanding
of modern application design,
including the micro
services design pattern,
we can see how Modern Apps are pushing
the limits of current automation tools.
Instead of being one large Binary,
now these applications
are composed of many parts which
are smaller, easier to write and deploy.
These smaller independent binaries have
led to on demand updates that can happen
at any time.
This is led to a rethink
of the tooling and
underlying infrastructure we're
using to support these modern apps.
These requirements have led to a new
set of automation tools like Docker and
Kubernetes.
Stay tuned for our next lesson where you
learn how to use the Docker image format
to containerize applications.